[музика]
і ви що було сплановано акцій це
треба злити його, і я вийшов з дому скоро
не тривають сили там написала таймінг
проекту бюджет проекту там план бика на
не проект навчальний план у насті до відразу
вийшло спонтанно ми відразу милий рахунок
сатрапа я кузьми простого тону в
правильному руслі 1 ж спочив із шахти
відв'язний колій ми по людину країн
зліва то через мене провели за видами і
ними сочі протез чого так а проблеми
з але й так з метро взагалі зруби ти і це
за раз ми миємо унікальну на ходу майже
що на це знизить а то я половина
німецький захід на його вирішення проблеми
[музика]
рабство і тішить процесу чи спочивання
каже а проти проблему сівби на неї це
під них тон я думаю ніхто
україні про на мене хтось пучок з до 1000
до інтернету можливість назад ще за
всі фантазії ще проблема спадок
начинка ми нинішніми
[музика]